YouTube what's up so so grateful that
you clicked and you're about to watch a
new youtube video but before you do - 1
2 9 3 1 5 7 3 1 that is my texting
community platform doing a lot of
one-on-one engagement in there and also
access opportunity first looks in that
environment
- 1 2 9 3 1 5 7 3 1 join it now and now
to the video you've been wanting to
watch they are but they cross over in
what they see so how do you but I just
started an online gallery where you can
go on and buy a print but the size frame
but they're fundamentally different
products they are well the only
vulnerability you have is if you don't
have secondary market dynamics on the
originals the reason there's
fundamentally different things is not
necessarily to your point if you're
physically in love with the picture
that's all that counts you well not
really because in my current well let me
rephrase in one man's point of view I
would argue it's not because for example
I don't care what a baseball card looks
like I care about what I believe the
secondary market value will be over time
if I care about a baseball card look
like I wouldn't just paid seventeen
thousand dollars for a Bill Russell
rookie card I would've bought the
replica for 18 bucks off of ebay the the
real business you're in when you're in
that business is having the potential to
create investment growth on the original
because that's the variable difference
of the product not the print or the
original agreed so do I take down my
site no oh you you what happens with
Judy Moniz from the Armonk art festival
goes on my site and she's like this
this guy well I assume that the same
thing that happens on where your
leverages on that KPI if you believe
you're the kind of artist that doesn't
have the leverage because there's print
versions as you can imagine you know
this every single great painting in the
history of time has had print versions
so if if you're worried is actually b2b
which it is in that environment where
somebody's making a judgment call
you need to attack that in a
conversation with that person not make a
macro business decision right if that is
the thing you're debating then you go in
and actually have that combo and say do
you that do you Jenny or Jenny value
Judy do you value this or does this skew
you in any way for considering me
because I valued the district the
awareness that you create and then she
gets to decide she goes no I don't give
a [ __ ] everybody does that or she goes
yes and then you make a decision that's
how I see that all right get right into
it this portion is like with me so I
think this is when you need to get
selfish like you'd ask your question
[Music]
hiring is guessing firing is know like
you gotta go fast that's how you get
[ __ ] done that's unfinished stuff out
this is the television and the
television is the radio before T's
[ __ ] would love for you guys to
do intros and tell me about your
business and then we'll go right into
hardcore Q a great to be Jerry Wesley
will say what's a source group we're
security risk management firm been going
art artists just started their online
gallery where were you from Nyack New
York Newark New York pleasure but I will
McCoy I'm the CEO for no bully which is
an international nonprofit again anti
bullying anti cyberbullying based in San
Francisco but we would do work worldwide
understand hi again hey brother how are
you good
ken Moskowitz Spanky as my friends call
me CEO of add zombies we write words
that sell anything we are an SQL
copywriting service yep I'm French like
David LaRoche so I'm obsessed by why the
best of the best so I travel the world
to meet doctor farmers athletes
entrepreneurs to deconstruct how they
think and then I provide a lot of free
content on what I learned from them and
it gives me a lot of credibility I'm so
G and now I'm I'm lucky to have Olympic
champions and and for us to help them to
grow what they do faster and also be
more fulfilled because I love psychology
and we have the biggest following in
France right now but the most important
thing for me is that we change lives
like letters from fifteen-year-old kids
with didn't commit suicide
because what what we do and it's it's
amazing for me to see that my next step
and it's while here I want to go global
I want to have that kind of impact
worldwide and I would love to have your
advice and tips on how I can leverage my
accent and who I am in order to reach
more people and just for you to know
it's not
I thought sure I love the business part
but it's a mission for me I'm playing
for the next 50 years I'm going to
create a legacy and I want to impact the
lives of millions of people so I say
that because sometimes I hear you saying
that young life and business coaches are
full of [ __ ] and it's true
but for me I work like so hard in the
last 10 years and I make difference it's
very easy not to be full of [ __ ] if
you're playing for legacy versus signing
people up to masterminds to buy watches
and skis like um I think I I want you to
commit suicide so I do what I'm doing
because you understand and it's great
yes good with a small group we can go
very hopefully we can go around a couple
times very specific like very specific
questions like we do it then I'm ready
to go super so a little bit of context
we got to guest chat recently so I'll
dive right in four legs to our stool
consulting training research solution
they remember shifted from a hybrid
government and corporates focus to just
companies now that's interesting from a
content and digital perspective because
now we can lean out a bit more in talk
about we're working with the type of
work we're doing those types of things
one of the challenges we found
specifically has been now that we're in
that space and can create
develop content started to do more in
the digital space is thinking about
audience so in the corporate space our
if it's our prospective client work or
point of contact is very different right
so it could be a chief HR officer could
be a chief security officer could be the
CEO could be a CEO or the spouse of
those people a hundred percent a hundred
percent so as I think about kind of how
we go about our content development what
are your thoughts with respect to
targeting stress if it's if you have
limited if you have limited resources
you pick one the leper is caught that
all of this is built on it's gonna be
your answer as well all of this is built
on context everyone's infatuated with
the content because it's important it's
the output your world might like however
all the upside from a strategy
standpoint is understanding context
because then you're able to create
content contextually right which
disproportionally creates relevance
which relevance and meaning something to
somebody is why every person in this
room is wearing what they're wearing or
what they're gonna eat is what they're
gonna eat so you know to answer your
question in a world where like hey Gary
I'm crippled it can be the CFO could be
the CEO can you see it you're like cool
right it's really as simple as that
my argument is you can get to a lot of
them by understanding copy right there
is no question to me that a PDF a deck
an audio file a video can be made and if
you rant on it as first-person or if you
create something amazing it can actually
touch on all three of the demos I can
talk about the financial impact of
something and the retention of employees
because of that decision and the
top-line revenue growth probably within
two minutes and then if I change the
copy on a LinkedIn post that expands on
that and targets a CFO and really just
narrows in on the financial
ramifications
I've now actually made one piece of
content with an additional five minutes
of post copy that did make it seem as if
I made three right okay great
that's how I think about it okay and I
know we got a lot done with fear and not
beer and stuff on that so I'll just keep
going around but yeah this is all about
investment I spend an ungodly amount of
time on investment for things that drive
my CFO crazy you know what's so funny
about me is people say I don't listen I
interrupt people this is that I just
have so much pattern recognition of
being an entrepreneur my whole literal
life and I spent so much time listening
when I'm not in front of a camera that I
gave you the answer within the first
four seconds we're gonna go through it
cuz I want to make sure you got the T's
in the eyes but we'll go right back to
it this is a 100% investment what's your
appetite for lack of margin because
there's no other way right which also
speaks to having to be able to be in a
place where you're growing the offense
while you're spending more time on the
defense Nix last night were within three
and decided to put a defensive unit up a
timeout which made sense except that the
Bulls scored five points in two seconds
we were back down I ate and had to call
another timeout and put back out the
offense that's the decision coach phys
Dale made luckily the next rally did one
but that would have been the critical
point where he lost because he decided
at that point it was time to invest in
defense and unfortunately the market aka
the bull said go [ __ ] yourself
yeah that's your game all the top-line
revenue you're gonna give up because
there's only so much you know
entrepreneurs like you and me think we
can do two hundred eighty percent not
100% just not true yeah there is a
number some can do 280 but that doesn't
mean you can do 390 and so that's the
game
the only other variable in your life to
play this out is what you're willing to
give up in leisure or time efficiency
most of what I'm successful at is
completely predicated I'm actually
having four minute meetings when it's a
four minute meeting instead of a
30-minute meeting that is if I'm really
starting to understand myself I'm like
all right zero waste
creates vulnerability because you have a
meeting and you leave and nobody knew
what to plug you just said you know but
I still rather do that for four minutes
than 29 minutes because then once I
realize a week later nobody know what I
said you have another 8 min of meeting
with the context of them not knowing and
you get it done and so now you're in for
12 instead of 30 yeah I'm a little dizzy
[Laughter]
that was a little nerdy mine's a little
more not as complex so I did my 10,000
hours on the creative side of branding
and advertising and then Malcolm
Gladwell gave you a bow pardon and
Malcolm Gladwell give you a bow no
unforgiving yep and about five years ago
I decided after well just to go back a
little bit I got divorced and started
thinking what can I do
versus what I can't do because I can't
do it good for you so I started painting
and I realized that you know five hours
would go by it seemed like 10 seconds
hmm and so I started doing that as
therapeutic exercise and people started
asking me how many I'd sold and I you
know so I started selling him I done
about five years of doing art shows and
you know 15 20 yard shows a year so many
my work selling it and that's a lot of
lugging it's a lot of insight from the
marketplace what people like what they
don't like I love that I've loved
interacting with people I love selling
the artwork yep then I decided okay how
do i monetize this beyond selling
original artwork because you know
everybody's an artist yeah so I just
recently started this online gallery on
this platform art storefronts calm which
is set up for our it is yep you don't
have to do a lot of development work and
I sat down and started to figure out to
myself okay I'd put a lot of brands on
them on the on the map how do I do it
for myself okay
and that's why I'm here because I'm not
quite sure how that position and package
myself to appeal to the two markets that
I'm trying to appeal to which is the
person that's going into home goods and
you're buying a $40 piece of [ __ ] yep
and to the person that's gonna buy
thirty five forty five hundred dollar
piece of original artwork yep well as
you can imagine you need to be in
different places and you need to show up
different but the good news is there's
only there's only ten twelve fifteen
places on top of something called the
internet that are good places for people
that don't have millions of dollars to
spend on media and the reason every word
out of my mouth has been tick tock and
Linkedin over the last four months is my
expertise over the last 25 years as a
marketer is to understand where there's
attention for a good price zero is the
best price
correct the fact that you can post a
one-minute video of you painting on
tick-tock right now and get 800,000
views for zero dollars is not available
to you sir anywhere else the fact that
people sit around and say things like
well I can't do that that's where my 14
year old granddaughter lives
there's only kids there people say no
instead of yes has anybody heard of a
granddaughter break it personal that's
not true it's getting older by the
second but let's just say was let's just
say it was capped it is only 12 to 16
year old females in America for ticktick
which it is not but let's just say was
has anybody heard of a granddaughter
taking a phone and showing their
grandmother this cool painting like
people are so funny
they're in the business of no instead of
yes
so whether it's tick tock or LinkedIn
those are two very important platforms
for you because you have to make content
for those platforms because you're
probably not gonna pour $10,000 a month
in ads you may I have no idea of
anything about you okay you're not so
those you have to take very seriously
you know that is the context that I need
to do a better job to my audience of why
I talk about it I just did it I'm glad I
did I hope Jason caught it like that is
the punchline forever
it was email it was organic google
search the reason I would sit and spend
seven hours a day in 1999 looking at the
ASP code of my website was I was getting
educated on how to show up first on
Google without buying Google AdWords
before there were Google AdWords for the
word Pinot Noir because if I know I did
147 people would go to Wine Library calm
in 2000 for no reason other than they
searched Pinot Noir and I showed up
first and then I bought ads because they
were five cents and that was a good deal
for me and I can afford to buy $10,000 a
month and on and on and on I'm not
throwing around my phone number to one
two nine three one five seven three one
for my community text platform for my
health it's because text messaging my
audience converts better than anything
else I can do and is the only thing that
I've seen including Twitter and Facebook
that looks like email looked like to me
in 1997 where 90 percent of the audience
that signed up actually saw you need to
please content in written audio or
visual clearly video for them for what
you do across the ten platforms that
matter we have that I don't know if
we've done that I don't know if we do
that later did we do it already you need
to do that you need to deploy self
awareness and figure out which one of
those you can do your business is highly
visual so we're gonna kind of need you
to be in picture and video form even if
you were in video form and people only
saw your back of your head it could be a
[ __ ] tool time home improvement gag
if you are so insecure and I don't say
that in a resume I stayed in the
compassion way if you were so insecure
that you couldn't show your face great
let's film you back to canvas to
audience but you need to produce
pictures
videos on the Internet it's more
important than making the art it's more
important than making the yarn nobody
knows you can't sell [ __ ] right when I
tell you that I started this company 10
years ago which got made fun of by every
one of my friends cuz building a client
service business is not a smart business
for where I was at in my professional
career it's because my belief was there
was nothing left except communication if
tomorrow I decided to pick a random
artist I would make them be the kind of
artists that could sell 5000 dollar
paintings because I would now
communicate everybody and that would
create demand the end got it thank you
now it becomes now what I just said to
you is oh you want to get healthier you
have to eat well and exercise and you're
like not Botox I'm like no you're like
not you know acid plant something no
you're like not no not steroids enough
you know got it now you have to do it
right and the way I best learn that
people will do it is how I got to you
have to be self-aware you might love to
write and then mousse and that may sound
crazy to a lot of people like he's a
[ __ ] artist that writes I think it's
kind of RAD if you wrote a crazy
manifesto I'm glad to hear you're a good
writer linked it with no visual support
that you just magically like enamoured
all of us with the written words of how
you came up with the painting idea and
then there was a click out to the
painting that might be intrigued less
people would see it cuz the friction of
clicking out more people may convert
because of the way you did it got a play
right thing I'm most proud of as I play
I'm okay with not doing well in likes
and shares or what's best practices
because I know I have to figure it out
not yesterday doesn't mean anything to
me linear phrase
yesterday means slightly more less to me
than trying to figure out today right I
loved if I'm alone I love the context of
yesterday I'd like that to repeat the
same mistakes and I'd like to use what
I've learned to deploy in the context
but today
the game not three years from now I know
VRS coming not interested not three
years ago everyone's so scared that they
massively overvalued yesterday yes I'm
struggling with myself about turning the
table from being behind the camera to
being in front of it in other words
there's a way to do it maybe not be in
front of the camera right right back to
the back but yes you know sell your
product now writing the product that's
just insecurity of the product you're
selling well yeah I'm aware
yeah I know you know it that's just you
casting your own judgement of like I
don't have permission to do this I just
started right guess what LeBron was good
as rookie here
maybe you're just [ __ ] naturally
talented I am I'm incredible I believe
it
but honestly honestly that's it that
makes so much sense based on the
narrative you like [ __ ] I just took this
up Who am I to charge 5,000 don't this
oh it's not that okay it's not that it's
the entering into the marketing myself
as the product versus marketing this
gentleman's business is the product that
goes to the insecurities in the product
right
I'm telling you whether it's whether
it's the version of Who am I or you're
right I like or you've overvalued being
understated or you philosophically have
put being behind the scenes on a
pedestal as a more proper way to go and
you're not a charlatan or a Fame [ __ ]
whatever you've decided in your brains
that's what we have to break down you're
probably all the above I believe it
right there too cliche reasons right you
know people gallery personal brand
that's so yucky I'm like cool call it
reputation is that better I gotta step
out for two minutes I'll be right back
yes sir ready yes sir um so for us as a
nonprofit I mean we do great work nobody
is probably right so the argument is
easy but when it comes to converting to
donation yes converting to new
partnerships yes getting that going from
awareness to active leaning in yeah I'm
super excited we're talking about this
because I'm going to have raised by us
event tonight which I'm on board
and when the Board of pencils of promise
and charity:water have some I would
argue that some of the best marketing
working might I'm very funny I'm very
comfortable in promoting my business
ventures because I like capitalism but
I'm very very quiet with my altruism but
I spend a lot of time on it I'm gonna
give you a really interesting insight
the number one vulnerability to
nonprofits is audacity if you if you
macro analyze the communication of
nonprofits they speak to us as if we
should donate to this and it completely
fundamentally turns us off why should I
you mean the way to educate people if
you look carefully and I'm very pet it's
funny to have spanky like I'm better you
know it's funny I was so I'm so bad at
grammar forget about I was just cuz the
way I learned and probably because I'm
probably dyslexic and because I'm an
immigrant there's a lot of reasons
probably but nonetheless I'm deeply
passionate about words I'm good at it as
a human they matter and and when I got
into nonprofit work I wanted to be
effective you know it was like hey here
comes the whiz kid and marketing like
[ __ ] I met her you know I rarely do work
but I did some work on this and it was
and I'm also very intuitive back to
quick answers I'm like oh [ __ ] these
guys are terrible at marketing because
they're entitled and audacious and then
when I started really getting into the
world and I'm not speaking for you but I
was stunned by how many people are
non-operational in the nonprofit world
right you have a lot of makes sense
right like both my kids could go that
route right you go away from the you
know the wealth creation and you're like
I'm gonna give back but you've never
done anything so it not only was it
audacious and condescending
it was ideological and not practical so
that is the huge vulnerability to why
nonprofits in the macro without knowing
anything I think you need to really
think about that you know how is that
manifesting in what you're creating
the answer is listen it's so fun to have
the prime of my life's work being built
this communications framework that made
no sense what I did it is starting to
make sense to people right now but
they're still grossly under estimating
what I'm actually doing there's nothing
left but what I'm doing
everything is a commodity except the
awareness and communication because of
how life actually works like of course
that camera is a higher quality of
course print and original is different
of course bullying is different than you
know cancer but but it's more
commoditized than people think what's
not commoditize is the ability to get
somebody to know and care to getting
somebody to know and care you first have
to deploy empathy not audacity it's the
reason we have such a problem socially
in our country there's no empathy from
either direction literally yesterday
morning on the way to work I had a 15
minute conversation with a woman who
told me that I was a very bad guy when I
spoke at a company last week because I
was using white privilege because I was
cursing and if I wasn't a white male I
wouldn't be able to do that 99.99% of
people would have deleted that email
because it was pretty left-field I spent
15 minutes talking to her I didn't find
anything new but I appreciated the
conversation you need to be really smart
you're right
nobody is against bullying more
importantly nobody actually cares and
once you get to that realization and
here's why you know who cares the person
whose kid becomes pre suicidal because
of bullying the same person that cares
about heart disease the second or dad
dies of a heart attack we have to get
more empathetic but we deployed too much
too much ideology like I'm spending my
life giving I don't need somebody
yelling at me like Gary you don't care
about [ __ ] the Turtles you can't
drink out of that [ __ ] you know you
know straw like I get it I'm like but
you're wearing a Gucci bag and textiles
are destroying our environment
we're in hypocrisy audacity mode in non
profit land but we have to do is go into
contextual creative at scale to create
relevance there's a video that I want
you to watch it was done by Sandy Hook
it was really good remember that I don't
know if you guys saw this but I was
actually talking to Katie because it was
a big piece of contention and that
convention it was a big
were stationed at vaynermedia because I
believe in long-form videos instead of
commercials and this was one of the best
I've never seen it was a video of what
it looked to be is like a high school
love story but you remember but it ended
up being in every scene while you were
paying attention to the sweethearts the
mass shooter was in the background and
you only figured that out at the end I
mean I got like crazy goosebumps it's a
three four minute video on YouTube it
crushed Andy who promised yeah you know
what we'll have Nick send an email to
all of you
he's probably looking it up right now if
he's not eating and he'll find it I
wanted the point is what's amazing about
bullying is it's a subconscious
knowledge that's the problem and what
you need to do is make a 2 minute 14
second video that is entertainment or
information that captures the National
Kony nobody [ __ ] cared about that
dictator in Africa until everybody saw
it on YouTube
got it
yep thank you how I think about it is
the Gary Vee model which is the Vayner
model which again Zac probably spoke to
and with Nick here and others here we
can go deeper into I think your
organization needs to put out a hundred
pieces of content a day I think that's
when you have to figure out I'd rather
I'd rather you spend two hours less
painting I'd rather you fire three
executives who actually aren't doing
[ __ ] but being in meetings you have to
make this is about ideas and making and
nothing else when you make that your
religion you start actually figuring
everyone's like Gary I mean I had an
employee who's been here for seven years
say to me on the phone the other day
when I said we have this huge Procter &
Gamble conversation I'm like she's like
Gary this is the staff we have like you
have to make a choice between LinkedIn
and Facebook I'm like no I don't you
have to stop being in dumb [ __ ]
meetings for two hours a day and make it
41 so I can have both figure it out you
have to make an african-american
Siddhant and asian-americans in it and
Latino Americans in it and Latino
Americans in Spanglish because then you
make C whoa why is this resonating we
don't even know that this was an
underlying issue in the last Hamm
community in San Antonio but by making
when you make 100 pieces of content
you start making a San Antonio Spurs
piece of content for Latin you know you
see one going that then gives you an
insight because you're getting feedback
and now you're like now we know what
two-minute video to make let's make a
video of you know an 84 year old and
what bullying actually meant and how it
transpired and what it actually meant
this is not about suicide and mass
shootings this is about an eighty
four-year-old who said seventy-five
years of unhappiness has four divorces
that were ugly not good has you know a
drug and like like you see where I'm
going and that's just one high I mean I
just wanted to hypothesis mode there's
seven hundred other things you could go
with but for you and for you and for you
and for you and for me and for every
single person this is a game of
contextual creative at scale deployed
against the platforms that actually have
the attention of people which then
compels people to do something and it is
not one vanilla piece of content seen by
everyone it is contextual creative at
scale right you know as you can imagine
now we're going very far-fetched but if
you're making a video of a may pretend
grandma that had a painting in her in
her you know in her kitchen for that
kids whole life and that's why you need
to buy one of my paintings for your
kitchen that's going to straight to
whether you say that because I sell I
tell people when they buy my art that
you know it's touching their lives
they're gonna be looking at that all
their life and their and their kids are
gonna be looking at it you can't put a
price on that yes why I don't buy art
because that doesn't do that for me but
I want photos of my family everywhere
cuz that does do that for me
but to your point like many many people
most people actually knew that with art
I remember everything in my parents home
I get it so and I'm not obviously
regurgitating metal dick you know I
totally get it
I'm not following I say grandfather
Zelasko that that is that is your
requirement its awareness but it's not
just awareness it's compelling
somebody do something compelling
somebody to do something is based on
them not on us so we talk down
We Need to Talk Talk got it thank you
that toad if you go through just every
communication you do comes from that
filter you'd be stunned by how much more
money you'll get that's very helpful
thank you you got it
so as my brand has grown and as we have
developed kind of a global awareness now
we have clients all over the world that
use us the opportunities for me to speak
and take bigger stages is occurring more
often and so looking at growing the
business further I realized and
recognized very quickly that every time
we document those those moments every
time we film those moments that then
turns into more content but it's not
necessarily content directed at the
brand its content around my brand my
personal brand so so in looking at
growing the brand further we're trying
to figure out should we leverage the
opportunities of me speaking on more
stages and of me coaching or working
with other companies because it's
interesting the questions that I was
asked a year ago a year and a half ago
were hey how do I write effective ad
copy now the question is can you tell me
again how you grew a business - from
zero to seven finger business in like
less than two years do you always answer
I listen to Gary B I do very I know you
did that's why I'm making that joke but
you know it's funny I had this really
surreal moment in in the Nashville
Airport I was speaking at a conference
and this guy comes running up to me and
I shared that I since you need thought
about it I said this guy came running up
to me and he like can I get it can you
sign my book
and I'm like sure and he said your book
changed my life I'm like how because I
was kind of in the mindset of Ben I went
on the receiving it right and and but
now that's happened a few times and I'm
like the answer is both okay
to your question both of course so it's
okay to diversify in terms of the to
many partners my filmmaker today is my
business partner when you said get an
ops guy my up my video bag couldn't be
here today so Brandon came along yep so
he is a blessing to my business that
came
directly from my conversation I remember
years ago I remember so financially you
share you share the business yes that's
the only vulnerability the only
vulnerability to building a personal
brand as a top of the funnel is who are
the other stakeholders who fear that
you're getting disproportionate leverage
and can leave and they're the commodity
I don't think Brandon has an issue with
that well I can't speak for Brandon but
I can promise you the answer that's
that's the answer to the question
the only reason anybody on earth should
not build personal brand at scale is
because somebody else who has financial
men vested interest subconsciously or
consciously doesn't like it nothing else
should stop anybody because it brings
business in its type of the fumble and
by the way your strength related
strategy holy [ __ ] look it's not even
just weekdays rather I know listen
listen I'm eventually people gonna
understand like I'm really great at what
I do and I'm very quite unusual for
giving it away for free at scale and
then if you want a deeply more
contextual sure there's things like
Boehner media there's 4d there's other
things but like it's going to be like
that forever it by the way if there was
documenting in video and YouTube when I
was 22 I would already be there because
I would have done the same thing and
everybody would have got an email and
e-commerce and search and YouTube like
you would have seen me make a youtube
video four months after YouTube came out
and said this is gonna be the biggest
thing and then we'd be sitting here and
be like how the [ __ ] did he know that
yeah I did based on based on what you've
been preaching with the LinkedIn
strategy I've been doing that
aggressively and I'll skin an average
day 150 to 300 new followers I'll see on
a weekend 2,000 new followers to get it
and I post LinkedIn his Facebook it's
crazy
2020 it's crazy but solid platform said
it a billion times some people like
nobody's doing very few people are doing
anything about it what's ironic is my
advice actually leads to my own downfall
if everybody listened to me and made
content then the organic reach would go
down because it's just supply and demand
that's how much I know people don't do
anything
I'm literally giving advice every single
day then is that my own detriment
so you are coming from an immigrant
family and I would love to have your
point of view about that so the French
business is is growing it's a family
business
it's like okay we are making for
millions
that's you're in France take you say a
lot about publishing out a lot of
content so we did 500 videos in English
and the only thing that's work is when I
do videos with other english-speaking
well-known entrepreneurs all right but
when it's just me myself yeah it sucks
and I would love to have your vision
what's the definition sucks it doesn't
get as many boobs yes a lot less of what
of what I can do when I do a videos with
like you know a well known entrepreneur
in some field or the put yourself a lot
of the Rings it makes a lot of use but
that that would happen if it wasn't just
English that's not a French English
thing or accenting that's a you're
leveraging brand equity from somebody
who's famous thing but you in in France
right now it's I make more views if it's
me speaking because you have more brand
equity in that market yes for sure
but also I can see that so my question
is if you were coming right now in the
USA or your father with not a perfect
English how you would leverage by
recognizing I can't change my accent I I
do even if I improve it but I wish I had
my accent it's more like I understand
what you're saying how do i I'm sure
that they can leverage who I am as a
strength but it's more by having more
patience and just putting out that
content and by understanding that
Americans are naturally deeply like
deeply rooted in America more than 50%
of Americans don't have a passport
so you just what you have to do is
accept the truth and execute on the
truth because it's like I can see the
growth of doing more interviews I can
see it's growing but me doing like after
200 videos it's like the same views at
the beginning I don't see improvement I
understand and that's and that's
frustrating I think I think there's a
couple things one just continue to
interview yes for sure and I'd love to
do that Hey as research it's similar to
some other stuff that we talked about
I'm very blogging so I'm right about
email I'm right about Google I'm right
about e-commerce I'm right about search
and here comes this thing that I think
is about to be big called blogging and I
look at it 2002 and I'm like [ __ ] I
can't write me too so I'm looking at it
in the history of my career from May
1998 to right this second there's only
been one macro trend that I didn't
dominate blogging
you're gonna have your accent yeah yeah
Americans are never going to accept an
accent more than an American accent you
just now have to decide with your
strategies there's two loops one
continue to interview at scale and do no
independent solo English videos yeah and
then after three more years or a year or
every year on [ __ ] July July 7th try
one thing that happens or go the other
way and beat them into it believed so
much in your message that you can be an
outlet look no different I will tell you
that when I hit the scene in 2009 wildly
high energy cursing I was wildly not
accepted I had a lot of pushback I just
made everybody succumb
it's really only two options and they
have one question about it's like you
say a lot about being yourself when you
do things like heroes and tunic that's
what is like the line the balance
between staying yourself in the video
but your self can for example I I would
not say that I'm an extrovert I'm more
diverse so I learned to speak because I
do a lot of speaking treatment but
there's a lot of people that do
extremely well that are quite I mean Tim
Ferriss is not extroverted yes sure
good there's your answer there's no
Brooke what's right is that Tim's Tim
and on me I hate when people try to be
like me I'm wildly entertaining that's
hard that's a talent I give a keynote
like a stand-up gives a you know
performance that's not going to be
replicated so you're having to be very
insightful as well yes I have other to
your point well thank you for like what
I think people get confused with me in
the other way is they just think I'm
sizzle I would argue that I'm underrated
intellectually because I'm sizzle in
this like introverts always like ah I'm
not like you I'm like bro I get [ __ ]
completely disrespected for my intellect
and insights because I am your gift is
your curst right so I'm okay with that
and everybody think I'm dumb I'm a
charlatan I'm full of [ __ ]
it's I'm not smart that's fine that's
the point
I think leaning into your truth is the
is the best because it's the fastest and
the easiest once you get over to hump
you got to get over the hump of judgment
but once you're over to hump then you're
fast I'm so fast because I had no time
to dwell on the judgment it's so you
know what's so fun about these things I
you know it's so funny analyzing the
most the reason I thought that this
would be good and I would be good was
how I started looking at Wine Library
the first full year after I left it it's
amazingly interesting when you can look
at something looking down on it versus
when you're in it
agreed it was crazy I started like like
that bursty I stepped away for a little
while but then like the holidays came
and like I wasn't fully removed I was
like this sucks this blows
this is [ __ ] this is [ __ ] up I'm like
[ __ ] those are all my favorite moves but
I'm looking at it like this versus being
there every day your thing is so easy if
two moves if you want America if two
loops you keep going or you keep
interviewing to build even more leverage
to then cash in or you also start
thinking about distribution differently
well you know one could argue the
psychology of the end consumer in
America is different on LinkedIn than it
is on YouTube and Facebook and thus your
accent might allude to European
intellect in LinkedIn that it may not
play out on YouTube yeah for sure I can
see that's the more it's about deep
knowledge the less my exit is important
everything is less important once people
see the truth every every [ __ ] email
I get is like I started off hating you
until I started really listening I just
would spend no joke if I was your
brother and we were like hanging out for
the weekend be like bro not another
minute ever in life you're not allowed
to say to me anything about an accent
just wasting time that's what everybody
does you understand I understand I'm
empathetic to it that's what people do
they spend all their time on the thing
that they can't control I don't do that
good I just I would like to know I
understand that less that's okay you
know
yeah that's all they don't know correct
that's right cuz it's a guaranteed
variable you know my question is more
what could be the way to not only not
speak about that but what what I did is
friends other every people told me oh
you are too young because I started when
I was 20 and I used that as an advantage
I understand so it's not that I didn't
it's not that I stopped to speak about
it I even I spoke I spoke a lot about it
that's and people start to say oh [ __ ]
and in France nobody was doing that
you're super smart if you want to start
your first video every time in America
be like before you talk about my accent
it's the M&M a mild thing of course if
you take control of your shortcoming it
becomes your strength and I love that
they DC it's what everybody misses you
it's weird actors that are super ugly
but they were smart enough to be like no
no this might look and they're like oh
weirdly attracted to Adam driver why and
I would love that for my I think that's
the new hack that I need to make content
about hey are you really not attractive
you need to lean in and reverse and
weirdly the confidence of not being
super attracted weirdly then makes
people think you are I actually see it
it's happened a couple times happens to
me every day let's get a couple more in
a little free form we've got five to
seven more minutes sounds good
reconcile for me this notion of being
the CNN for your segment yep but don't
be developing selfish content that's
intended to basically interview input
right you know coop who would you think
of in my context for in the security
space of what type of interviews would
you see as interesting what makes me
think of Fox News right because those
guys are always scaring the [ __ ] of
everyone look I think I think this is
what's so great you probably have a good
sense of in a security landscape who has
equity you know what I always say is
like look at your b2b magazines and look
at the conference's in your industry and
look who's on the covers and look who
are on the keynote speeches and then
invite them to be on your podcast and
all those people since I'm one of them
always want to do a podcast right got it
mm-hmm
that's how you Matt Beck and then you do
some Google search sure
random [ __ ] like top 50 people in
security and privacy like right right it
just random work yep okay you'd be
surprised how many people say yes
even if you had you know again everybody
says no why would Sarah Magoo the number
of three security person in the world go
on by podcast I don't even have one yet
right don't say no for the other person
the first thing I thought AJ about
vaynermedia cuz AJ's practical which
means he goes to no right because he
thinks what would I do and he would
practically look through everything and
say no I'm like that's nice most people
make emotional decisions now you're in a
crapshoot don't say no for the other
person right the greatest accomplishment
I life is I had a super-duper-duper
overweight nerdy friend in college and I
promised him that he would get a super
pretty girl before the end of college
and it was a simple game of volume he
just I finally got him by sophomore year
to ask everybody and eventually somebody
said yes that's life
I thought it was getting a puppy that
works too but like but it was a really
interesting exercise of my thesis there
was nothing on paper that made what I
saw happen happen for any logical way in
its most narrow animalistic way of life
and it happened because you can't say no
for the other person and you have to be
okay with a lot of nose right and if
you're not okay with a lot of nose you
never get to that miracle
sure lesson learned is you get used to
no karate man everybody's used to know
in certain things and not in others I'm
only used to know and love know and
business but I also didn't like asking
girls out in high school I didn't like
no in that context right right so that's
the thing right you super can have to be
fine in one thing but another thing
you're not as fine with and it's just
recognizing that and just going to a yes
culture it's just yes culture that's all
it is
it's just making I actually think it is
practical what's the [ __ ] is gonna
happen if you email : pal and he says no
right god forbid he says yes you're off
to the [ __ ] racist
maybe he's bored today right
maybe his niece said to him that he
needs to get on podcasts and he doesn't
know better that you know just doesn't
mean anything right mm-hmm
don't say no for the other person you
went through this you probably were
going wide at first that's what got you
there
wait a minute I always tell people I'm
the easiest when I have something to
sell you want to get to me I'm
impossible you want to get to me what
I'm selling empathy or case with
sneakers I'm easy
everybody's got an unlock Gary the other
day you know I was pissed I sent
something to you as a little thank you
yes and they [ __ ] up the thank-you
note and I'm actually glad they [ __ ]
up think you know because I've been
wanting to sit down with you not for me
but to have a real contextual
conversation about mentorship on my
podcast and I would love to if you have
time at some point have you come on
alright send me an email well I'll look
at you I'm looking everything now for
next year done and we got a lot of stuff
going on so I don't want to [ __ ] you
I know I know very open to it cool I
have one question you say that we need
to publish 100 piece of content are they
right now 100 right well you know like
to me you know the exact number my
question yeah I heard in one of your
video that right now you attract a lot
of talented people but like what could
be your advice to attract attract are to
find talented people to do all the
things when you are not at your position
right now yes Colin Powell by making a
video tomorrow and saying I'm looking
for people
d-roc became the adjective or pronoun or
now and a rudder [ __ ] do you call when
everybody calls themselves a dirac I
wasn't who I was then so you mean like
you've got a huge advantage everybody
here is a huge advantage every
seventeen-year-old in America and in the
world wants to be a creator people don't
get it this has nothing to do with
leverage of the person this has to do
with the interest and supply of the
makers every [ __ ] twenty two-year-old
hey do you want to work at a shitty bank
or do you want to work at a corporation
or do you want to be a video blogger and
post produce for YouTube and Facebook
they'll take [ __ ] 1/5 left but 10% of
rich enough to have their parents
subsidize them not making money to do it
40% of them are smart enough to or are
ideological enough to choose happiness
over more of a salary and then 50% will
say no not to mention there's a lot of
my argument on creativity is about to go
in another direction I'm trying to spend
a lot of time on 60 to 90 so I think
copies super important and I have this
wild ideology in my mind that there's
all these retired men and women from the
Mad Men era sitting in Florida and New
Jersey in New York is 72 years old bored
as [ __ ] so tired of everybody saying to
them that day that they can't that they
can't do anything that they don't
understand how to take a selfie then
this set meanwhile they're brewing in
the craft of word Manship and putting
together words blow away 98.7 percent of
the people because they have 40 years of
experience to go along with their talent
and would rip their arm off to come to
an environment like this and work for
$15 an hour to be a copywriter I'm
completely convinced and I'm gonna
execute on it you're correct
I believe it you can't because there's
too much scale there's supply no no not
really
awesome the world is abundant if I
thought you could beat me to it I
wouldn't have said it out loud I love
the idea though because it's funny
that's that's a real challenge is
finding good quality
who can write you have the people who
are literally Reuters you literally you
have literally the people that wrote the
greatest commercials and greatest print
ads of all time sitting right now again
let me say it one more time
being made fun of for not being
technology advanced made fun of oh
grandma you don't know how to take a
selfie you hadn't reverse that took a
photo you meanwhile can literally write
the greatest copy in the world I tell
people I don't want copy writers I want
people who are amazing storytellers of
course that's what a great copy writer
write but they say you're saying that
you're saying the literal interpretation
yes we jumped on you mean the truth
right by like so I am a great copy
writer I have no grammar skills that
would never get hired by Jacob booty
gray or Vader for that matter because I
don't know how to put it together but I
know how to put it together
well the secret of copywriting is write
like you speak a hop-on said there you
go right instead of like a machine
that's just right like you speak yeah
even better the way I speak makes people
do things so thus that's why my [ __ ]
work looks less - it could be a hundred
percent yes more people are saying short
form short form for formal I see long
form - what do you see for the future of
that both will work six if tomorrow I
found out that Star Wars the next one is
nine hours I would go and watch it and
if I watch a six second vine that's [ __ ]
I'm out in two seconds what do you think
for brands and wynacocha presentation
stuff yeah
oh here's how it works well for long
form back where you're at I gotta run
after this I apologize but really good
to see all of you guys all you need
it's like Dollar Shave Club dollars
people go makes a video and then
everybody is like oh I gotta make those
right all you need is one 13 minute film
that about Fiji water that actually
[ __ ] works and the whole all this is
is a sheep world people don't think
independently they need an example make
one video and you're off to the races
nor do Wayne Wade Budweiser video really
mattered
three minutes forty seven and that's a
long-form ad but
I think where people get hurt brands
have spent brands have been ripped off
by fancy directors and producers
agencies and by every ad agency to make
these kind of like documentaries hundred
I totally sees it you'll appreciate this
all of it is based on merit nothing
scares me make the best thing of
something and you will win the answer is
yes just be good
that's what Facebook and YouTube and all
those people get mad at me for long
forum because it's against their
algorithms against their best practices
my theory is make a video that somebody
wants to watch do you know many people
watched my eight hour vlog and [ __ ]
Dubai was a [ __ ] hours sitting
watching me it's not [ __ ] this is not
[ __ ] avatar make sure if people want
to watch always works
have the freedom to make something that
people want to watch when you're in
client services different game right
yeah that's where things get hurt a lot
of times clients do it yeah clients get
clients get what they deserve then try
to make this McCann everyone's done
everyone's a designer yeah everyone it's
all subjective and right yeah that's why
all right love you guys thank you
[Applause]